obama called so much attention has
returned like a rock star in Cuba
people have taken it so much affection and
affection that could be the next
president if he then proposes wants a
very nice man yes he has to do
very elegant lists and I take it
tattooed of the Cuban flag
elche because it was what I was taught in
our country and I ask you many thanks
to come to our country
Well the first thing that the
Mr. President of the USA what
real intentions has with our
country what idea do you have to take on all
the blockages and what we are most
affecting thank you for taking the first step
you delayed but thanks for giving the
first step I would like you to make a
bridge well fine well well large where
we could move from one place to another without
problems as friends as brothers
that continues to advocate the afternoons world
especially by immigrants and
people who are in relationships with a
man for me of 30 people because he has
done what exists in the USA has made
more part that we have this in common
the goods
cables
hide